i mean for me right now it doesn't even
feel like an anime
you know it's i mean i mean it's like
it's it's an american production
obviously it's kind of like we're about
to get into that
it feels in the same area as uh avatar
avatar yeah
then i also consider avatar anime i mean
japanese people consider it anime it's
anime like
i didn't know i started anime until i
actually watched all of avatar and i'm
like i can see where this argument never
ends yeah i mean
you know with this we're getting into
semantics you know it's it's
it's whatever because the only thing i
would say
it's fantastic yeah anime or no it's
fantastic i don't give a [ __ ] if you
think it's
it's an anime or not it's just a
fantastic show in general all i was
trying to say is like
i don't think people more people in the
anime community are talking about it
it's just because it feels different
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah let me feel
this let me give you an anecdotal story
i was talking to a guy and i asked him i
was like which animes do you like
he goes one anime that i watched
recently that i really like this is on
japanese like i recently watched
despicable me 2. it was one of my
favorite animes
of recent and i was like that that
completely
hold up it made me it made me realign
this whole argument of like
is that is this anime is this not i'm
like listen this guy dead ass
this otaku self-proclaimed attacker who
told me despicable me
is a good anime i'm like you know what
why are we arguing
i think it's like i think it's a stupid
argument this is a clown argument
yeah i just killed the argument it's
literally just like the west versus the
west yeah
we made this argument out of nothing
yeah yeah yeah yeah the japanese are
like we're not we're not part of this
it's that simpsons picture where like
the people are surrounding the two
monkeys fighting
that's that's the japanese watching
anime fans argue about if this is anime
i felt like we were like this is how all
religious fighting started right
yeah like the 100th century we just made
we just made an argument out of nothing
because yeah because i mean [ __ ] you
ask a japanese person monsters zinc
shrek it's all anime it's just crazy
because in japan anime just means
animation i've never just had like
[ __ ]
hit i got hit by a truck when he said
despicable me as an animator
it hit me man it hit me real like [ __ ] i
was like this man's built different
saying that right
there would have been a different story
if you was like the minions of my waifu
like that would have been different
dude i don't know i don't know why
they're obsessed with minions obsessed
with indians in japan it's [ __ ]
everywhere i hate it
so we visited joey's new apartment like
last week yeah and uh joey you just like
youtube yeah
slight detour it will get back on topic
because
he was showing us around and he shows us
into the last room and he's like oh do
you guys want a free gift
i was given a free gift from the moving
the moving department do you guys want
it and we're like
sure joey what is it dead ass just
brings out this massive
minions mini fridge and expects us to
take it
and he takes this thing out and we're
just looking at joey being like joey
what do we want to do with this
what are we gonna do with this and he
was like maybe we can put in the trash
taste studio
like joey the trash taste studio isn't
your dumping ground
i have a gift is roughly translated to i
need to get rid of my trash
please please take it i will pay money
because that's i guarantee that's what
they did to joey they were like
joey joe i know i know we're moving all
the stuff for you but here have a free
gift
have a minions mini fridge and they're
like thank god we finally got rid of
that [ __ ]
we're doing you a favor it was
despicable oh my god